like Trinity for instance it was
challenging to play here because she's
so still and every movement it's like
you know what I mean it's so upright
it's so there's this quality of of
Stillness with her that isn't really my
like I have to like I had to put a lid
on like every little thing and at the
same time access the life right and
right that's at times I would feel
completely
um like just the mark on the floor just
the T that we stand on like I would feel
like that was jail you know what I mean
like I just like it was like
I not have a fatigue I mean I literally
it was like that can we take the middle
T out like I'm already confined enough I
I need the mental bandwidth to like
Channel something right